[Music]
we're back in the podcast again
um with a friend is praying today
[Music]
yeah
you're really jet lagged huh
jet lag when I go
West uh-huh it [__] me up like going
east I'm fine even all the way to like
Europe yeah uh
I'm sorry it's the other way around
excuse me excuse me going east [__] me
is that what I said [__] me up
it's fine okay yeah because like we're
coming West um when you go west you you
you you you just go to sleep early
and then you wake up early I move Now
with uh traveling because I'm going
today actually to London flying oh you
are yeah 5 p.m today Sam we'll be there
till we see you yeah yeah
um I think you're gonna see the husband
and all that it is 9 A.M by the way so
he's just made it on time I wasn't
worried about it wait a minute I wasn't
worried about it wait a minute
this is a good luck man this is slick
turn it close tough guy that close
because what time is it back what time
is it it's 9 00 a.m it's 9 A.M everybody
9am man I like the sweatshirt with the
shades thanks it just came in from
outside
[Laughter]
should we do something to celebrate the
fact that we're back should we should we
sing a song should we uh sure should we
just do the podcast should we
everybody looks a little bit different
just a little older just a little yeah
Meg's hair looks cool thanks mag did you
curl your hair I this is the way my hair
is naturally oh so I just didn't really
straight up ringlets yeah there's a
ringlet in the front that's very it's
you're like Annie yeah you're kidding so
naturally you straighten that [__] out
and you say stop it with the curls and
you you tell them and then I re-curl it
I I straighten it and then I try and
then I re-curl it why because because
they're they're not fancy when you don't
do it right the short answer is because
like this is a little more unpredictable
yeah and the long answer is wearing my
hair naturally is me accepting like that
perfect not being perfect is like okay
so like so you talk to your therapist
just before you came in to do this yeah
she actually cuts my hair it's like
it's okay well people who cut hair are
kind of therapists aren't they right
like they they they get I think the
people who've cut my hair and know more
about me than most most of my friends
yeah yeah except for now we're doing a
podcast so everybody knows everything
yeah now everyone's all well Abby did
this the hairstyles actually yeah so
um hairstyles for sunny for many years
so
um she said hey hey Abby roll okay well
you look Glenn looks tan I'm glad it's
been in Hawaii I've been Hawaii for 10
days but I've never I've never known a
person in my life that puts on sunblock
the way that you put on something and
have and have for 25 years for as long
as for as long as I've known you wait
how do you know how he puts on yeah I'm
confused by that well we use we live in
California sorry let me break it down
for you we live in Southern California
right right and we used to we used to
actually uh we used to share an
apartment in Venice California so this
is why you picked up all the sunblock
yeah but you guys also know all this
information already
um I live I lived with Glenn in Venice
California about a block from the beach
and we would go to the beach three times
a week yeah where do you put on sunblock
what do you mean where do you put on
sunblock on your face and your arms and
you put on sunblock on the beach and so
I would know about Glenn's Sun blocking
methods try spending so much time
he's filed them remembered them
seriously for later years it's
impossible
it's impossible not to because it's
impossible not to because this would be
Circa 2005. if I had to guess yeah go
ahead he has a very particular their way
of putting on sunblock which is
different it's like very
very Civic and measured and maybe time
consuming this is a guess definitely
consuming
it's the amount the amount first of all
the brand let's start with the brand
again I don't know exactly what brand it
was but it's a high-end five brand it's
high and it's it's 2005. I don't think
it's yeah it is it's interesting to me
it is that kind that doesn't rub in all
the way yes it doesn't just be
unfortunate that's the unfortunate uh
you know uh result of having a
non-absorbent face
get the storm I guess I was using like
what the mineral sunscreen like the
white stuff that just turns your face
like straight white uh well whatever it
was you we'd be in a sea of 20 people
and I'd I would like be able to walk
down the beach and I would see you know
in the distance I could pick you out
because I would see 19 human beings and
then one person who was purple uh I know
purple person well so how does how do
you use sunscreen you turn a color that
Meg's sweater is I don't know what the
reaction is
he's a very high-end uh thing and he
puts it on and doesn't absorb in and it
turns his skin he said that it was
high-end he did not say it was high no I
don't know that it's high-end I I it's
not it was it was sunblock that nobody
else was using at the time it was some
kind of you know industrial grade it's
just pain it's just like [__] and yet
still I've got sun damage all over my
[__] face but I do think and we've
established that you're not as healthy
as Charlie so
by a different metric by a different
metric yeah by the other metrics I was I
don't think you're healthy at all yeah
well the mind yes
the body possibly definitely after these
10 days okay I don't think I'm healthy
either I think that's yeah I don't know
I drank my face off for 10 days guys
just drank this [__] faces
on the ride home good for you on the
flight home because they offer you that
that a mai tai and it's tough to resist
you know you're on with the Hawaiian
Airlines it is but man I wish they'd
make no no well it was the mai tais you
know at the at the resort and at the
beach you know that when you're there
then they're just they're coming around
and you know what was the earliest you
had a drink this is what I was on
vacation I'm always like what's the
earliest I'm gonna start at noon oh okay
you know I'd wait till noon usually yeah
I'm not I'm not a mimosa guy I don't I
don't that's not my jam yeah uh but but
if you had a drink at noon would you
have but you have the ability to just
have two or three and get you have like
a nice little bus and then just stop for
five hours yeah and then put it back up
again you start drinking noon you're not
gonna keep going until oh no don't sleep
at night oh yeah yeah yes me personally
that's that's how I roll yeah but I do
like to get a buzz going on I'm not I'm
not a big fan of having one drink I
don't understand that I don't understand
that either one drink one one drink you
know that just like
what's the [__] point of that you
know what I mean yeah yeah I've only had
four drinks in like two and a half
months and they were all right in a row
right because I don't get the point I
had one night where I was like I'm just
gonna [__] drink tonight and so why
would you do I don't know you want to
feel all the feelings yeah I can do one
I can do one depending on what it is but
I can be like I could be like all right
end of the day one a single beer and
that's it get the calories into me but
not feeling anything I never used to be
able to do it do you do a beer like what
Rob does a Manhattan where it's like
yeah
how big is the glass of beer are you
filling a glass of beer like you're
drinking a 40 ounce yeah so it's one
beer I don't get it yeah it's like and
Guinness isn't even that high in alcohol
how [__] up do you need to be well not
[__] up I don't want to be falling
down I want to feel the effects of the
alcohol otherwise I'll just drink water
yeah exactly I'm like it's not worth the
calories uh you know it's not worth the
it's that you know juice isn't worth the
squeeze it's just like it's like having
a it's like having a thimble full of
orange juice you're just like what's the
point of that I'm gonna have a whole
glass of it I don't count calories well
I don't me I just mean what's the point
like unless you're enjoying the The
Taste
I do enjoying the tasting experience and
then and then I'm enjoying the fact that
I've only had one right so then I'm like
okay that was nice I had a beer I I
guess so what you're talking about
alcoholism
well Charlie you're taking you're taking
pleasure in the same thing
you're in the control of just having the
one as well right I don't think that's
what it is I think he just said that he
said he enjoys the fact that he's just
having the one yeah like I won't so
there is a there's the there's no none
of the guilt along with it when I have
one but speak if you guys are having too
many maybe you need uh intervention
intervention intervention intervention
yeah today we're talking about my
favorite episode I'm really excited
about this which is season five episode
four the gang gives Frank an
intervention uh it aired on October 8th
2009 and it was written by Scott marter
and Rob Rozelle and directed by Fred
Savage uh D Dennis and Charlie attempt
to Stage an intervention on Frank who
has gone off the deep end meanwhile
Frank attempts to bang Aunt Donna who
Mack is also trying to bang yeah I I
love this episode I enjoyed watching it
for probably the 50th time uh what did
you guys think about it of all the
episodes we've done so far in this
podcast I would encourage the creeps and
the listeners uh to go watch this
episode just go go watch it it's a joy
that's what I was thinking I was like
this is a good one if you had never seen
the show to be like hey what's this one
it'll give you a good sense of
of who the characters are and what the
show can be and
um top to bottom funny I left the entire
time yeah yeah yeah same Danny amazing
Peak peek Frank Reynolds right here uh
just the best
um a good lesson for any young comedic
actor in like the absolute absence of
vanity from both Danny and Mary Lynn as
Gala snail is unbelievably hysterical
and all you want to do is watch them
yeah you know just like uh be filthy and
gross and disgusting
very very funny I want to point out you
know for the young folks out there when
when you do something like this like a
show like this and and and and the
episode I think is widely considered to
be I think by a lot of fans a a classic
like one of that gets a lot of people's
like you know in their top 10 or
whatever
you know and I remember after that
episode it was probably right around the
time that we were getting on Twitter
right and and starting to be able to see
comments after an episode would air
everybody was talking about wine in a
can wine and a can wine in a can that's
so funny wine in a can
the fact that we did not then take that
idea and start making a wine in a can
it's just so stupid
it's so stupid that we didn't do that
that's like a huge thing now wine in a
[__] can yeah and and and and not
only is it conducive to Violent hand
gesture I am loving this canned wine
thing I think it's brilliant I mean I'm
active I'm gesturing with my hands and I
don't feel restricted I mean if I was
holding a wine glass right now I'd be
spilling wine all over the goddamn Place
yeah well look it's not intervening on
Frank for a lack of good ideas well
that's for sure as we've established yes
but the most brilliant thing about it is
like sometimes you only want one glass
of wine you don't want to commit to a
whole bottle and maybe maybe you you
know maybe you only want to drink like
what if you want to this man just not
say he doesn't want to drink just one
this is actually I'm not saying me
you wouldn't go crazy but you'd have two
or three yeah yeah this is like me
getting to the age of like hey man
yeah that's all right I used to drink
Sherman
I went out with Charlie one night and we
just had a couple of drinks at the bar
and he's like let's get chimei I'm like
that sounds fancy let's get that and
it's a delicious beer and I was like
let's get a few more and we wound up
having I don't know three or four Chamas
and I was annihilated what's the alcohol
what's the all of it it's a lot I love
it maybe monks I think isn't that one
but monks probably not anymore right it
doesn't sound like something monks would
make doesn't it buddy
nine percent alcohol by volume oh my God
I sneak up on you yeah very near wine
levels of like right yeah that's yeah I
mean Wine's like yeah 11 like 12 yeah 12
13.
I think we drank like five like maybe
five five or six of those very quickly
that's that's the equivalent of yeah
drinking
like almost a almost a dozen
so you can abuse yourself yeah the sun
damage or oh boy well now that you guys
are getting older you're not getting
real weird with it I don't know how many
years on this Earth I got left
I'm gonna get real weird with it because
that oh yeah it'll hit a Tipping Point
on the on the back side of that yeah
I'll pick it back up again I'm getting
more
uh not weird with it but more just sort
of self-accepting you know to be like
yeah it'll just don't have to
clean up the edges a little bit just
kind of of Life yeah what do you mean of
me just trying to be like yeah just be
just just be you and let the dad jokes
fly and whatever comes out is you know
don't uh don't try to filter it too much
letting go of that vanity like you're
talking about letting go of that vanity
trying to one of the funniest scenes of
the entirety of Sunny I think is Danny
gargling all that beer
gorgeous
stink a disgust
[Applause]
disgusting
let's talk about this so we're on
location in Philly
and we've been out and about it was very
early in the morning so we go down there
at six in the morning I think we've been
up late enjoying Philly enjoying always
making a show uh Fred Savage was a ton
of fun to be with in town and uh Fred
Savage was was Savage a Savage yeah we
would go out he was having a good time
climbing out of the top of limousines or
whatever he was doing yeah why don't we
have a limousine we would we would never
ever traveled in a limousine but we
weren't with him yeah but but a
limousine was had maybe it was a prop
car or something I can't remember oh but
he got a he got pulled over by the
police and got a ticket uh because he
climbed up out of the car
and was like yeah like somebody
screaming out of the sun yeah of a
limousine why did we have a limousine
like a high school prom kid yeah was
there an episode
we wouldn't have taken one of the no
listen we did not have a limousine Fred
Savage got a limousine why and went
around with probably lafaro and some
other women I was not there I was in the
we were in the car yeah I was in the car
I wasn't there
very early morning we were out all night
and then turned right back around and
went to set and
um and Danny was with us all night and
and then knew he had to play inebriated
that morning so we just kept it going he
just kept it going I just kept it going
he just kept it going but we had a
reporter come down oh [__] right who was
doing like a Morning Show talking about
Good Day Philadelphia yeah good night
like I guess someone from fx's you know
press Department had had booked this
interview for us which was rare like
this maybe this is why we didn't
continue to get a lot
he was doing that gargling thing and you
know beer all down the front of his
shirt talking to the reporter and she
started kind of giving him [__] and so
he was giving it back to her now this is
live on a Morning Show and you can see
me and Charlie I can see in the camera
Charlie she's like what's happening I'm
standing next to Danny and I'm realizing
oh I'm guilty by association so I start
like inching away
because I don't want any part of these
two both of them yeah God knows what he
was saying
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
yeah yeah because getting help you know
getting to know yourself you know that's
a lifelong process right and as David
Bowie always said
change yeah and we're gonna have to pay
for that I'm gonna have to pay for that
oh just changes just as David Bowie said
changes yes that's right
you like Bowie and turn and face the
strange
with a better help online therapy you
know oh you don't have to face a strange
all you got to do is uh face the screen
yeah I tried better help actually and I
can personally test that it was helpful
for what I was going through I think the
part I liked most about it is that it
was all online so I could um make
appointments really easily and adapt it
to my schedule do you think David Bowie
ever had a had therapy you think he went
to a therapist well I'm going to say
anybody who wrote the Berlin Trilogy was
going through something Rob knows about
the Berlin Trilogy Of course I do mm-hmm
well either way you know I bet I bet if
he had the option of online therapy he
would have been using it what could have
been to that almost Anonymous artist
yeah he had a lot of potential that guy
yeah he did and you can discover your
potential With Better Health visit
betterhelp.com sunny today to get 10 off
your first month I want to say it again
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Sunny
[Music]
yo fellas uh you know it looks like the
rainiest year ever in the history of uh
California yeah it looks like it's
finally coming to an end man finally the
Sun that we all signed up for and you
know what the sun means means the shorts
got to come back out guys yeah it's time
to get those core shorts from viori back
on you know get a little sun on them
walking sticks or you get the choice you
could go for the the Biore Sunday
performance joggers you can protect the
entire leg I love a good jogger I love
it it's always a good look what's super
versatile I work out in it and I can
Lounge in it but I will say that it's
getting warm guys and it's it's time for
shorts Fiore is an investment in your
happiness
happiness okay for
the 20 off your off your first purchase
so you
think the versatile clothing on the
planet at viori.com Sunny pod that's
v-u-o-r-i.com slash Sunny pod not only
will you receive 20 off your first
purchase but enjoy free shipping on any
us orders over 75 and
free returns that's a biggie so what
you're going to do is you're going to go
to fury.com sunnypod as we've
established that's
v-u-o-r-i.com Sunny pod and discover the
versatility of Yuri clothing
ladies and gentlemen
life moves fast it does it moves really
it goes fast doesn't go fast you know
Starbucks ready to drink coffee delivers
an uplifting boost that helps you
tune into the moments that matter
wherever you are that's right Starbucks
ready to drink coffee is here to
announce that they are ready to help you
enjoy every moment every single moment
of my life that's the claim you don't
think it's you you could enjoy every
single moment if you really put your
mind to it yeah I don't know I mean I I
don't I have moments I don't
particularly enjoy I have moments that
maybe I don't want to enjoy and there
you could be enjoying those moments if
you charge them up a little bit with
yeah with Starbucks ready to drink
coffee now can I suggest a bottled
Frappuccino chilled coffee drink now
comes with four flavors you may suggest
that how's that going to make me enjoy
taxes or like being stuck on a Tarmac at
the airport okay well I got two
softballs for you to answer your
question okay right off the bat it would
give you the energy and the focus to to
to do those taxes and then going through
the TSA line
I don't know you got energy you're
energized you're full of life and you
might find a lot of comedy in those
moments right comedy that you can draw
from and and pull into your
professionals yeah you mean I can start
a stand-up routine about the airports
the first guy ever do that right yeah
it'd be different that'd be good cool
yeah and you would enjoy every moment
yeah but with the audience just want to
be you know cover our bases here with
the audience enjoyed another sort of
airplane routine well it depends have
they had their Starbucks ready to drink
uh coffee drinks you know before you're
set right right oh two Starbucks minimum
at my stand-up show I'll put that on the
flyer right Starbucks coffee ready for
right now ready for right now you're
telling me ready for right now yeah you
can shop the full lineup online or in
store or wherever you buy groceries
there's just a part in that scene where
the at the very end when he does the
final gurgle but it's incredible because
he takes a sip of beer and then he
breathes like he opens his mouth and
breathes and then he does that thing
which doesn't make any sense like where
does he keep the beer while he's I'll
tell you where he keeps it he's vomiting
in that moment they're taking it down
and it's coming back up watch it again
you're just disgusting a disgusting
animal
[Applause]
maybe not all the way down to the
stomach but it's definitely down in his
throat because he takes a breath and
then it comes yeah it comes back up and
bones all over that's extraordinary
watch it again wow that's trying to
figure out how you would do that right I
didn't notice the breath before so I
just thought he had it in his mouth and
and it's such a funny scene and also
yeah I mean Rob's whole like waving away
I mean I'm sure there's bloopers where
I'm laughing on the page it's not really
that funny like the biggest joke on the
page was that he doesn't realize Rob's
walking behind him and that they've been
walking together which is a funny idea
sort of like from an intellectual
standpoint but then when you get to a
man just like burping and barfing beer
on himself and being so disgusting it's
like Rob has to walk away
it's so funny
when you're shooting something you have
to worry about content something called
continuity and I don't know if everybody
knows what continuity is but basically
like you know if you're if you're in a
scene and and let's just say you've got
a thing where you have to
you know something spills out of your
mouth and all over your shirt
why don't you continue this conversation
but halfway through take your hat off
continue it and then put your hat back
on then continue and then just cut back
and forth and then we'll show people
yeah yeah so if take one you know if
take one you're you're wearing a hat you
know and then
suddenly and you go to lunch you come
back you forget you're wearing a hat you
go to lunch you come back you get you're
still shooting the same scene you come
back somebody you know somebody forgot
to put the hat back on you all of a
sudden you know some takes you got the
Hat on something and sometimes you're
talking to the person and then and then
you cut back to the other person to see
what their response is and the next
thing you know they're wearing a hat
again yeah and then it's just super
weird you know like it doesn't cut
together
um you know so so if you're doing a
scene where you're spitting all over
your shirt and you got to reset that
shirt every single time you know what I
mean I guess unless in this scene I
guess it it just we just established
that it just started that way yeah but
like I mean still like the the
continuity of something like that is a
nightmare and you'd have to you know
there's some the Wardrobe department on
the first take seas that he's spilling
it all over his shirt and there's a
little hair dryer on this shirt yeah and
their job is like they probably didn't
have it oh my God we don't have a double
for that we don't have it wasn't in the
script of course right right they didn't
have a dry shirt and even if they did
they would had to have 10 of them yes
being like that from the top in the
scene you're looking at Danny's shirt
and not his face you have there is a
point in time where you can get away
with a pretty bad lack of continuity and
I think that's when the energy of the
performance is so interesting and
engaging you'll see that in like a
Scorsese movie where you'd be like oh
wow that's just this is a lack of
continuity and like Goodfellas or
something and then yeah that's crazy not
quite hats off hats on there are some
continuity things that are like too far
but sometimes you just gotta you gotta
get the gun continuity today and like
sometimes you just don't know like why
or when something happened you're like I
don't have that
so this is for yeah and then it feels
like it doesn't make sense because
you're not you're not sucked into the
reality of what's Happening yeah you're
actually like pushed yeah it kind of
takes you out of it right yeah it takes
you out of it because you're like you're
like wait I swear you know that's what
you don't want right you're doing you're
in you're actually having a really good
scene like you said and then the next
thing you know you're like wait was did
he have that didn't he have a hat on
before did he but it is amazing that how
you will not notice it if the scene is
good enough and is compelling enough to
Meg's point where you're looking at
somebody's you're looking at somebody's
face
yeah no I know it's it's just it's weird
and and that's what you don't want you
know because it will take you out things
to jump and like look awkward right you
just don't want to be strange
foreign
[Music]
what's happening huh in fact I had a
little coat yeah Tommy Boy
oh my God buddy do yourself a favor
it holds up there's a bunch of movies
that do not and by the way that one does
oh for sure yeah no I I I know and it
wasn't one of those things where I was
like I don't want to watch it let's I
just never I don't know it just never
happened I missed it but it's happening
I love Christmas oh then you'll like
Tommy no I mean I I was obsessed with
him and I don't know why I didn't used
to do that fat guy a little Coke bit to
David Spade while they were together at
Sno like it was like the bit he would do
in the right because they would write
sketches together and David Spade was
like basically I would write and he
would be around yeah and he would just
you know doing bits like that guy in a
little coat
um he just puts on David Spade's coat
and then like it's just because he's
like in a little tiny ground try to
cheer him up
um yeah that movie is great I will I
will as soon as I as soon as I watch
welcome to Rex and my wool
then transition into by the way I did
tell Rob that I did start walking
watching uh welcome to wrexham oh and
it's it's great thanks yeah it is a very
very enjoyable enjoyable show we should
watch Tommy Boy together man
watch time well we watched Anchorman
last night and let me tell you something
that also holds US
20 years old a lot of good laughs 20
years old came out in 2004 so 19. I
don't like that I know that's a great
lesson in that you don't have to have
any straight characters for a movie to
work everybody can be completely well
you see you see like uh Christina
Applegate's character starts straight
and then they were like this ain't
working and then she just goes Brazil
yeah also like work is so
relative right there are tons of people
who would watch both those movies and be
like these are awful
they're wrong but right they're out
they're dead wrong they're dead wrong
but they're out there well there's a
bunch of movies that we did watch that I
I mean I think objectively of course
it's not objective but I think are just
straight terrible but I'm not gonna say
which ones they are but they were very
popular I wish you would yeah I've a lot
of the a lot of I find that a lot of the
80s comedies
do not hold up and I don't mean I don't
mean just in terms of like the blatant
misogyny racism and all that kind of
stuff you know that would that was for
some reason acceptable back then it's
more it's just they're just not funny
why is comedy not age well
that's so specific to the time you live
in yeah it's all about the time and
sometimes but it it often does it often
does so when it doesn't it really stands
out to me because like there are
comedies from the 80s that that totally
hold up their comedies from the set did
they make comedies in the 70s sure it
was a Bleaker time yeah cheers for bleak
huh sure well like mash was considered a
comedy and it is funny but it's also you
know yeah pretty dark yeah it's about
the Korean War
Yeah well yeah it's a it's always uh an
exploration of the time you live in and
the fact that it can that it sometimes
can transcend it and also if you if you
could you have to put it in perspective
all the time so half the time like my
kids will watch something
even in Tommy Boy and be like oh that's
not funny to them because they've seen
it a thousand times because somebody
ripped it off it was new for us it was
new for us at the time like you have to
understand that at the time nobody was
doing so you're watching Grouch remarks
you're like nobody's doing the big
glasses and the mustache thing you're
like this is this whole enhancing look
at this but but there's this I've
noticed a lot of movies from the 80s
that I thought were so funny back in the
day it's not even that it's not even
that the jokes aren't Landing it's that
there aren't any yeah it's like it's
like there's a there's like a killer
there's one movie in particular that I'm
thinking of that has
so many it has like a lot of really
really funny moments in it and then
large stretches where I'm like
is there a joke in here
should I just say what it is yeah Three
Amigos
it's like there's whole chunks of that
movie where it's like there's no either
there's no jokes or there's jokes and
I'm not getting them or whatever and
then there's moments where it's like
it's so funny well okay I'll go I'll go
you a step further we watched a Tommy
Boy and it was a grand slam so the next
night we were like let's watch Black
Sheep because it's kind of like the the
spiritual Seeker yeah and I remember as
soon as we started watching it I was
like all right I have the same
experience when I watched this 20 years
ago it [__] sucks it sucks and it's
the same two guys and the reason is
because it's just a series of sketches
there is no period of time like Tommy
Boy is actually a pretty compelling
emotional story with a bunch of really
funny bits because the actors are
incredible whereas Black Sheep was just
bit after bit after bit after bit and my
kids got bored they wanted to turn it
off yeah
after bit after bit after bit and you're
not bored right this is not really tied
into anything like emotionally in that
so like why does it work something no
but there is a story there there is a
there is a legitimate story yeah that
that is a sign of the times I mean it's
about there's got to be a story in Black
Sheep it can't literally just be a bunch
of sketches it's not a sketchy yeah but
a collection story I don't even know
that I could tell you what it is so
maybe that's right therein lies the
problem right if there's not enough of
something for people to just sort of
attach to yeah with an emotional through
line then you just yeah like like Tommy
Boy is like they're actually when when
when uh spoiler alert when Brian Dennehy
dies who's Tommy's dad is actually like
pretty emotional and then the story is
very clearly about Tommy about David
Spade's character never having a brother
and Tommy needing a brother and they be
and you like watch them fall in love
Yeah Disney model right like yeah it's
like the parents die and then the child
has to go on a voyage yes yes right and
and in Anchorman it's about it's about
trying to break the glass ceiling and
having the times change and women come
and be a part of what the boys are
trying to trying to do and you know and
like how we have to accept that well
Sonny's a good example of why you know
one particular story resonates and maybe
another one doesn't and uh intervention
is all about uh trying to help Frank and
him like emotionally like why yeah what
is it about this episode I can tell you
exactly well
for me it's that this episode has a
number of like really funny Runners
small things that like dot through the
whole episode like your lips all turning
red which is really funny and it's just
such a funny progression as the story
goes on that you're also the last scene
everybody's lips are totally dyed red
when you're having that conversation
with the intervention specialist
um there's that there's the use of the
word intervention that like changes over
the course of the episode leading to the
funniest thing where where then Mac is
talking about how he wants to bang uh
Donna because Barbara was the best sex
he's ever had and then Franco's
intervention intervention like time out
like he's using it in place of like
timeout yes just the evolution of that
word and how everybody uses it becomes
abused yeah and I think the other thing
is that the the there's a uh guest
character played by Susie Nakamura
um who just does such a great job of
being the straight character that you
guys are all uh revolving around and
being so crazy and there's so many funny
scenes like when you go to hire her in
the first place and you're telling her
that she needs to bring a gun to the
intervention because Frank's gonna have
one and then you're talking about
catching him in a net and then she
points out that Dee's drinking wine
during them trying to yeah there's just
so many things her performance is great
like watching it again being like wow
it's so grounded and real yeah that's
also funny and funny she thought she
found a way to be the straight person
and still find her ways to be funny in a
very real way yeah love that she's doing
the like care she she has like a lot of
compassion which is just a funny thing
to bring around the energy that you guys
have like I think maybe my face she's
really trying to do her job yes I think
that's why it works right yeah really
really trying she has so much compassion
for these people that she shouldn't
um but I think my favorite moment is
when Frank thinks he's getting roasted
what the hell going on
YouTube not your fault a boost I've
always wanted to be roasted oh wait let
me just switch gears here
fire up this spliff wait wait Frank hold
on um everyone's here today because they
care about you and they want you to get
well
she ain't funny next time the best line
in the episode yeah we quote that line
all the time all the time was this the
first idea was this the first episode I
know we've dealt with guns in the past
but was this the first time we
established that Frank carried a gun
with him at all times when you say you
know he's got this little pistol with
him that he carries with him he doesn't
really hesitate I feel like that's the
first time we said it's always on well
that Frank has a gun that's always on
him I mean we've used the gun we had
we've had arguments about the gun but
what was it Frank's guns or what was it
our gun that we kept in the bar no Frank
even we established it in well I know we
used it in the in season two when Dennis
and Dee have a new dad right because
he's on Facebook and he's [__] firing
the gun we've had multiple arguments
about it yeah but did we establish that
are you saying do we establish that it
is all it's always on him
I think that's the first time we used
that joke and that by the way it being
always on him is something that we've
probably picked up and dropped and you
know well it's so funny when you lure
him down to the bar for a grease fire
and he comes in wielding the guy yeah
problems
oh yeah I just love it I think it's so
funny oh the one thing that did start in
this episode is Nightcrawlers first
mention of nightcrawlers in this episode
um who do you guys remember who came up
with yeah
this episode feels like so much of the
amazing
sort of idiosyncratic sense of humor
that they brought to the show like
really specific weird things like
nightcrawlers and doing what Frank says
they did Monster Energy drink and drive
home and I think she gave me poison ivy
no we get a bunch of those Monster
energy drinks and drive them it was
awful I think she gave me poison ivy
that is exact those guys yeah that's
those gaskets
actually that might be the best line in
the episode yeah but I even remember
these lines
and mashing it and mashing it I'm sure
that was scripted you know you're just
smashing it yeah I also love that she's
like I'm giving him a handy under the
table and her and Aunt Donna says
something like you're supposed to be
sexually active you're not supposed to
be funneling your uncle yeah
yeah she played it so straight that I
wasn't even sure that she wanted to be
there at all
you know what I mean like she played it
so real that I was like does she I
thought she got the sensor early on
since that she did not even around this
season where you where most likely we'd
make an offer to somebody of of some
stature and obviously noradun um had
been on Saturday Night Live Forever
um and the author would come in and they
wouldn't have never heard of the
television show but they saw that that
Danny was on it and they thought oh okay
well this will be safe because Dad
because
he's in the scene so I think I'll be
good and then they show up to set and be
like
what have I signed up for I I've made a
terrible that's the impression that I
got from Nora Dunn who I I love Nora
Dunn and and yeah for the our younger
audience they may not even know her from
Saturday Night Live because that was
like maybe pre there watching SNL days
but uh she was so awesome on SNL I've
always loved her but yeah I definitely
got the impression that she was like
what the [__] is this yeah I mean when
we were working but but I mean she was
lovely script no she was not no she was
she was she was fine she wasn't like
you know overtly mean or whatever but is
I don't know there's like maybe a little
bit of a standoffishness or like it
works for the character though it works
so great for them and maybe that's what
she was doing maybe she's just a
phenomenal act I think it might have
been she was just playing like playing
the characters the character is exactly
how am I supposed to deal with these
lunatics yeah that's that's entirely
possible um but I don't I don't really
remember what she was like on set so I
can't speak to it but there's probably a
thing right where you're used to doing
like big shows and you come down
and
we have these little cheap looking
cameras right Charlie and I were just at
post last week because we're cutting
season 16 right and we're doing this
wonderful episode that Meg directed
um where where we're bowling and and
we're watching some of the footage and
it's sunny and it looks like [__] and we
recognize that but then we shot a couple
of the sequences in super slow-mo
there's a flashback moment on these on
these incredible cameras and it looks
like film and it looks so great and
we're watching it and almost like our
hearts are breaking because we're like
oh that's what it could look like yeah
and it would be a different show and
we're gonna have to degrade it to make
it match on some level right we'll
probably have to degrade it or it'll
feel stylistic and cool yeah either way
where we use a nicer camera for some
sort of stylistic flashback thing but
either way like any actor that's caught
on like looks cool looks better looks
more attractive more cinematic and and
we've just like destroyed our careers
ourselves as clowns
[Laughter]
clowns
clowns on videos
it is yeah
but you know the the the way we're able
to shoot the show with the tiny little
handheld cameras
Keeps Us Nimble and communically is
great it also allowed us to shoot say
that very very very intricate bowling
episode
um with multiple I mean so many
characters so many Side characters it's
so tricky and we were able to do that
how many days did you shoot that three
days plus one scene that's insane yeah
that's insane you shoot an episode like
that oh at least at least oh yeah yeah I
wasn't stressed at all no no
but uh you know it isn't seem stressed
that was acting yeah was acting you're
holding it all together holding it all
in yeah you seemed like you had it yeah
I mean it was fun I knew it was going to
be funny because it was all you know I
knew it was I was just like this is
gonna be a great episode from the
beginning
speaking of continuity that's really
tricky where you know you have bowling
pins like balls that are returning down
lanes that might be returning down in
one shot and not and then and take two
and if you want to cut between take one
and take two but I made a serious error
during that uh that I would if I got the
whole thing to shoot over again I would
have given you guys all assigned seats
that you stay in every time you're not
bowling because I thought it would be I
was like well when you bowl you don't
sit in the same seat the whole time you
like kind of mix it up as you so I was
like I'll be like verite you know but
then we block shot but then it makes
sense it's an absolute [__] nightmare
because the continuity is just a mess
it's a mess one one moment somebody's
sitting there next minute they've got a
hat on they don't have a hat on the
Hat's backwards it's nuts but there's a
thing that happens right where you get
you cut you get to all these like great
performance moments and then you find
the right music and then you massage the
sound and and uh
in uh on a finer film you do some
beautiful color work on our show not so
much but uh and it all kind of comes
together we're actually gonna have to do
some color work I gave them one color
note we never give any color notes
um but I was watching a lot of the raw
footage and these cameras and the
lighting and the way we shoot it for
whatever reason it's it's picking and
the definition it's picking up so much
of the weirdness of the redness of our
skin and so in certain scenes some of us
are just like bright red one that's
right right yeah
you can absolutely fix it but we have
that that's the kind of coloring there I
feel like we should have had a level of
grain to it which just dirties it up
which is just like you can sort of do a
blanket grain over the thing and which
because it's gotten so with the TVs now
and the cameras and by the way
everyone's probably watching at home
with their Auto Motion correct on yeah
they're like why does this look like a
[__] BBC teleport well that's because
you don't know how to use damn TV or or
the TV company has ruined entertainment
for you yeah but
um I have it's the default setting it's
the default setting it's the default
setting you turn the TV on for the first
time in the default setting is to ruin
everything to ruin everything you watch
uh unless you're watching uh
[Laughter]
no I'm I'm very aware that we've spoken
about it multiple times and I am very
very deliberately speaking about it
again because it is a problem it needs
to be needs affection these people must
be stopped one thing can I say really
quickly from that scene with Donna where
you're where uh Gail's mashing it and
everything I for whatever reason really
love the line that Mac delivers where he
goes I hope you like it Chris because it
is burnt
his breakfast and I swear every time I
make breakfast that like goes through my
head at some point like I hope you like
a crispy because it is burnt yeah I love
that so that whole scene top to bottom
yeah right yeah the Smashing of the
windows you're always saying did you
kick in my door that's definitely murder
result did you kick in my door I kick
yes in no yeah I did come into the
window now it's going to be a security
concern but you're always
which is funny
which is funny for now you know 30 years
from now and I'm like well that's not
funny you can't break into a break into
somebody's house the robots blast you to
death right oh the the house robot yeah
the house robot the house robot again
will incinerate you yes and uh yeah so
um some classic Sunny lines came from
this episode there's a lot there's a few
actually uh well I don't know how many
years on this Earth I got left I'm gonna
get real weird with it but I like the
second part of this line actually which
is meanwhile block the wind I'm gonna
roast this bone meanwhile
[Laughter]
yeah my God there's not enough salt in
the world for her which is a great I
love getting angry at her for making you
feel bad about yourself yes yeah that
was an interesting little spinner
thinking that that was really really
funny it's like yeah getting mad at
somebody yeah to force you to have to
solve them away why did you make them
insulting someone right why did you make
why do you do this to me yeah why do you
make me why do you do why do you make me
like we all lose we all nobody wins your
sister Charlie actually got to Salt the
snail so how did it feel when you were
actually you know really satisfying and
the way salt moves throw it it has a
nice Arc to it but to close that Loop in
the episode you say that you did not
enjoy yeah yeah you did not enjoy no you
feel horrible I feel terrible he didn't
have to do it when she's irritating us
and we don't have salt on us we we
inadvertently oh you do a great bit in
the first scene where you're talking to
her and you do a sort of salt flicking
gesture
he's like clearly laughing at the end of
the scene I'm sure I've started going
like that and then Caitlyn started doing
it she caught she's she caught me doing
it to start doing that and then you
start laughing and to cover up the laugh
you start doing it yeah
a very funny cold open too I personally
love any cold open that ends with you
guys just looking at each other for a
silent beat and then the titles hit like
you know he uh he says yeah and this one
it's it ends with Frank saying flush
that turd down the train and then he
walks away from you guys and you just
sort of look at each other and then it
goes gang gives Frank could ever
mentioned yeah I think it's funny was
this the first time uh I noticed this
because we just put it in another
episode this year and we certainly had
it in an episode last year but the
bagpipes of playing Amazing Grace was
that the first time we've used that
because we used it probably oh uh yeah
because because then we used it again uh
when sweet when when we pretend and the
baby the baby death yeah did we use it
for mac and Charlie die
that's gives a speech
I don't think so sir no maybe not I
don't think we had I think we would have
had we found it yeah there's there's a
few things like that that we have used
multiple multiple times definitely the
Sugar Plum Fairies oh yeah sure again
we're using it again this year
something sneaky happens right
sneakiness sneakiness and diabolical
activity
[Music]
foreign
we do get asked about athletic greens
quite a bit yeah yeah lots of people
writing into the show asking Meg all
kinds of questions about what it is and
how you can use it and so what we're
going to do right now is we're going to
have Meg just go ahead and Tackle all
the questions and the answers right now
Meg do I need to be an athlete to enjoy
athletic greens you don't I drink it
every day not only are they wondering
like how do I get this stuff they want
to know how to get it for free is that
right and by the way I get that like who
wouldn't want something for free yeah
stop damning me I'm not giving out free
athletic greens oh you're not oh sorry
okay
athletic greens has less sugar yeah
that's not a question but it does have
less sugar yeah less than one gram of
sugar and no GMOs no artificial anything
it's also keto paleo vegan and dairy
free and gluten-free to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free free this is the thing you were
talking about one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs that's of the ag-1 with
your purchase and all you got to do is
go to athleticgreens.com Sunny and and
listen that is important you got to do
the slash Sunny part otherwise you won't
get the free things and Meg doesn't get
to eat so again that's athleticreens.com
Sunny to pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional Insurance that's what you're
getting there
foreign
[Music]
pills no oh no
yeah I realized that um I was paying for
a subscription service a streaming
service that um I didn't want and I'm
not going to name names Paramount plus
um uh I wanted to watch um Yellowstone
which I really really enjoyed and then I
scrolled through some of that other
stuff and I was like meh don't care but
I forgot about it and I realized that I
was paying this monthly rate and I
didn't realize it until I went to to
rocket money so how did rocket money
help you with this rocket money is a
personal finance app that helps you I
first of all identify what subscriptions
you have because it turns out I had like
I mean 40 subscriptions that I didn't
even know I signed up for are
automatically signed up for they help
you identify them and then lower your
bills all in one place well that sounds
very useful do you have any idea how
much the average American spends on
subscriptions a month I would say at
least two hundred dollars a month it's
that's that's exactly right yes okay
yes but basically it's going to help you
stop throwing away money yeah nobody
likes you
it's gonna maybe help you cancel your
unwanted subscriptions it's gonna help
you manage expenses is that what that's
what it's gonna do yeah I think that's a
service that we should be providing
rocketmoney.com Sunny the slash Sunny
part's important rocketmoney.com sunny
rocketmoney.com sunny
foreign
[Music]
well have you guys ever been to an
intervention
either your own or someone else wanted
to I I've wanted to intervene on some
people but uh no no never I've had
conversations people but it hasn't been
a like an official full interview there
were no professionals Consultants no it
was more like hey man I just want to
bring this to your attention yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah imagine if it was
you right walking into a room and then
every bunch of people you know are there
like oh [__] here we go here we go yeah
about I think I think so so at the time
that we were making that episode Jill
and I we were we used did you guys watch
the show intervention I used to watch it
because we watched it religiously oh
yeah so I mean I wonder if that's I I
must have come in been like I saw this
episode of intervention maybe we was
talking about that yeah it was again it
was time yeah yeah that's what it was
based on I mean I mean that's what the
idea was based on because right and you
guys never watched that show no but a
hundred percent I remember if that was
if that was the the beginnings of the
conversation that we didn't know it was
in episode until I believe it was Rob
Rozelle was like what's the difference
between an intervention and a roast and
then we were like okay now now
yeah right right right right right and
my favorite moment in the whole episode
is that when you want to list the things
of how how Frank's um has affected you
and it's because you're annoying
affect the following ways you are
annoying
you go to help Charlie write his letter
to Frank you're like I'm assuming I'll
write yours down and you're like yes
and then there's another line there
illiteracy what does that word even mean
I was still like denying it in this
phase of the show right which is funny
we should maybe look up some there's a
lot of bloopers from that scene from oh
oh from the two of you guys oh yeah but
what is it but what is it but what is it
is that in the bloopers though is it
I've never seen that I don't remember I
remember us laughing like having a
really hard time getting through this
a lot of these scenes were tough to get
I want to know I want to know I want to
know what I you've said you said
I need to know what it is oh the night
crawlers yeah yeah and then I love the
that Frank when you talk about what it
is in front of Frank and you're like
intervention yeah
oh man oh this is such a good one well
what is happening
yeah the classic uh classic what is
happening line where did the sucking
thing come from did was that that
scripted that's I think the idea is that
like a snail is just very moist very
moist creature until you salt it just so
funny you know and so I think it was
just a byproduct of that like it's just
such a funny experience no I I and her
talking about how her mouth tastes bad
that was that was not in the script but
she was sucking wait a minute there
the very first scene we ever this
doesn't make sense I thought the very
first scene we ever shot with Maryland
playing Gail was a scene
where she was sitting across from
somebody at a restaurant
oh wait was there we cut the scene yes
because there was a scene with where
Frank
well no so the okay so he says so
there's a scene where he takes her to
gugino's yeah talks her into this into
this proposition when you say you should
bang snap
holy [__] man I forgot yeah and I
remember because because we must have
shot that first and then we watched the
funeral scene second yes because she
hadn't found the character she was like
literally we were we hired her I mean
it's not she she was a friend of ours so
she didn't audition or anything we were
like she'd be great and she wanted to do
it she's so super funny and then she
showed up and we realized that none of
us really knew what the character was I
mean we knew what the dialogue was we
didn't know how it was gonna fully
manifest itself
and so I remember throughout the course
of shooting that scene she was finding
it we were finding it we were giving her
a lot of feedback a lot of notes really
try this try that you know it was a lot
of trial and error throughout the course
of that scene but I don't think that I
don't know that that's why we cut it we
probably cut it just because it was one
of those scenes where he realized like
you just don't [__] need it you don't
need a scene where you set up that
they're gonna go do it you just go do it
and based on like what her character was
it was like this character doesn't seem
like she needs any talking into doing
this yeah right right she's grown into
her body she's not a virgin anymore yeah
I love that yeah and the original
conception was that there was two
garbage pills that is correct and I
don't do you remember the second one
there was a name there was a name and
it's a boy and a girl it was a boy and a
girl because they were supposed to be
mirror like if Dennis and Dee were
Cabbage Patch Kids these were the
garbage the Garbage Patch Kids yeah
yeah we did we came up with the name
yeah but it never made it through the
script that's right we we wrote it into
the script and then the script was too
long and then we just cut it it was
getting too fat yeah and it was too it
was too many people to try and serve us
but yeah that was the idea it was but
right we were supposed it was like we
were the Cabbage baskets but we
remembered her this year in the writers
yeah we remembered it this year wow and
then barely remember that seen but what
the the the good job yeah but we did
shoot it I do remember yeah yeah I I
just I only remember it because I
remember us trying to figure out who
what the character was and what was
funny about it and like how like what
the physicality was and I think we were
even [__] around with different
hairstyles yeah oh yeah yeah and having
her dress kind of like a child uh-huh I
think I don't even know that that was in
the script yeah man kind of is in there
right she's got that like green shirt
with like a cartoon character on it yeah
yeah yeah
definitely
you know Zone though she was dressed
like I had a friend and I went to
demented here's a story I have a story
okay
I was in a bar in Providence oh [__] I
might have told the story and uh the
idiots were always afraid we're gonna
get yelled at yeah yeah yeah I won't
name names but one of my Rhode Island
Buddies were at this bar in Providence
Rhode Island
and uh there's a girl at the bar who is
only wearing a Cat in the Hat shirt and
flip-flops right like yeah like she's
got no you're like does she have pants
on and her hair is greasy and The Cat in
the Hat shirt looks kind of dirty and
she looks like borderline homeless and
she said trying to talk to us but but
she's got like a gallon snail behind and
we're like okay hi how are you good to
see you and uh and then we're we're
seeing whatever band we're seeing this
the bar is called the living room in
Providence and you could like you could
get in like 18 and up you know uh but
then you could like get beer
um and we're going through the night
we're having a good time and we look
over and my buddy who I won't name
is on the pool table making out with the
Cat in the Hat girl as hard as he can
they're on the pool table going full
like kill a snail make it up and I
remember he was hammered I remember the
whole ride home all he could say was
don't know don't care man don't know
don't care we're giving them grief about
it
um but and I remember that being the
well both Margaret mcpoyle yeah I was
gonna say and the Gail look just sort of
talking wardrobe and like can you give
me some kind of cartoon character yeah
long potentially pantless we can't tell
sure
nothing Margaret yeah Margaret was
always wearing like the long yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah she got an answer
back what not quite right Robin
not quite right Robin you know and that
would have been really funny but you're
right it would have been like not a lot
of room for it in the episode yeah uh
now I kind of regret it well not good
right now
not quite right Robin could just be like
someone we knew in high school too I
mean that a character named not quite
right yeah not quite right Robin's
pretty great yeah that might have to
make its way into season 17. yeah should
there be one we're gonna have uh the
dentist system this season and Martyr
and Roselle have asked to come in for
that episode so I think very good
favorite of theirs oh yeah yeah
okay let me get that men on yeah we need
to get them in here yeah people need to
meet the infamous Rob Rose I know they
were too busy writing your show to they
were too busy writing the show
um to be in on the podcast somehow I
found the time but they couldn't do it
so we'll bring them in now yeah
I will say this Okay so we've been off
the air for a little bit but we've been
making the show and we've been uh we're
now we've filmed everything and we're in
the editing room and most of it's cut
together with three quarters of the way
through the editing
how you guys feeling about the season
how did you feel about making the show
this year
how do we feel about making the show how
did you feel about the process as always
result the filming of the show was an
absolute blast
um the writing of the show was absolute
torture
uh the editing has been fun
um Glenn you're you've been gone for a
little while but you're coming you're
going to come back and which is nice
because it's good to get some fresh eyes
on things yeah next week to top of the
week we're all kind of free to get right
in there and it was it was good we we
wrapped and then I went straight to
South by Southwest to promote the film
Blackberry in theaters May 12th
[Music]
uh oh well you know what that's when
Fool's Paradise comes out May 12th you
know competing competing films that's
crazy
did a movie yeah different in different
years did we completely did yeah when
did when did we shoot Fool's Paradise
you shot your stuff in 2018
2018. yeah and then yeah I just shot
black bear and they're coming out on
there will be in theaters
you could have a Glenn Howerton double
feature you can see a film that I wrote
and directed boy and I asked you to be
in it too you were unavailable oh attack
on a veil's not true that's 100 True
what did you ask me to do actually did
two two different things I think you
were [__] boy number three
one two three and you're like I'm always
talking about for you I'm always you
didn't ask me I did you might have been
you might have been busy like doing
science not on the first pass on the
reshoots I asked you oh on my first pass
I didn't you know I had Glenn but I
didn't have too many stunning people and
then when I did my big reshoot I was
like I'm using all my funny people David
David also in the movie I cannot wait to
see this new version of it I've only
seen uh a version of it I know you've
changed so much last cut I saw was in
2020.
I loved it back then you're gonna love
it more now I haven't seen the trail I
want to see a trailer for yours by the
time this airs the trailer will have
dropped great
Charlie I saw the trailer for your movie
It's amazing unbelievable I love it I'm
so excited yeah I do the trailer is
unreal well we're talking about this
this season this year and how we felt
about uh the process oh yeah no I was
saying I was saying I was at South by
Southwest and then I got back from South
by Southwest and I immediately got
covered yeah and so I missed the first
few days of editing because of South by
and I came back and had to miss like a
week because of covid and then I went
straight to Hawaii
some real really funny episodes by the
way the the show's coming out what June
sometime in early June so you can watch
you can watch Blackberry you can watch
Fool's Paradise and you can watch sunny
in in succession and you're gonna be
something full dose you could watch
succession and you should watch
succession all in succession and Tommy
Boy and Tommy Boy
um what do you guys think the effect of
doing the podcast on the season was
because this was the first season that
we wrote Oh I did really good from a
writing standpoint yeah because I think
it was helpful to kind of go back and
just
be so in on
what our show is and what our techniques
are so that when we were writing
something I don't know just feeling like
really close to the show in a way uh
because I feel like the episodes are all
really strong and feel like
throwback I don't know well I I don't
wanna it always like amazes me that it
feels like we come up with all the ideas
for all of the episodes in like two or
maybe three days of like blue sky it's
crazy and then it takes weeks and weeks
and weeks
yeah so we have one episode that came
together at the very end because we had
an incoming text from that's right
no no reason to be make it a secret [__]
uh it was an interesting season to write
it's it's definitely getting you know it
gets challenging to try and come up with
new new things each year it's always a
challenge to write the show it's never
not been a challenge to write the show
it's never been like well that was easy
all it is all it is is fixing mistakes
it is you make a thing and then you're
like what doesn't work how can we fix it
constant continuity errors
you know what I mean that that only
matter to some people and don't matter
to others
hey dude and take one you had your hat
oh we should put a challenge out to the
creeps and listeners okay to maybe
um
if there's any continuity issues that
people have noticed one of the ones that
they've known point out any major
continuity you mean like there's a
cameraman in the shot
is that in the early season yeah maybe
just general well General mistakes are
tricky because we did establish certain
things and then just through
intervention on us
give us a roast mistakes yeah like for
example Max says the best sex he's ever
had in his life was with a woman and
then another one yeah you're very
straight yeah yeah but but always that's
the evolution but but but the mom fetish
thing yeah it takes it to the next to
another level you know what I mean like
in some ways I could I could justify
like the fact that you were into women
back in the day because of more of a mom
a weird mom thing a gay man that also
wants his mom to love him yeah yeah so
if we can look at what things we've
established that we've evolved that's
one thing but things we've established
and then just disregarded or if there's
just straight continuity I know one
thing that people are going to bring up
and and it's a big one and we're going
to sort that out this season so oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's gonna be fun yeah I do think this
season has a lot of things for that are
just like straight up gonna please fans
the show yeah okay so let's tease that
one a little bit that that is something
we have established very early on in the
series season one season one a character
we established that that fans continue
to bring up whatever happened to you
never talk about or you just completely
dropped this character and we'll find
out and we'll find out this character
yeah well that's titillating enough to
go out on I think Meg said tit
[Music]